[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 22 septembre
voici les titres de l'actualité locale
en cette journée mondiale du rhinocéros
cette nouvelle ou à kitty un mâle de 3
ans va débarquer au zoo de thoiry dans
une semaine ce rhinocéros blanc vient
rejoindre sur place deux de ses
congénères il remplacera numériquement
vince qui avaient été abattus par des
braconniers pour sa corne il ya quatre
ans depuis la rentrée la pratique du
sport en association se fait sur
présentation du pass sanitaires pour les
adultes et à partir du 30 septembre la
mesure serait élargie aux 12-17 ans
comment se prépare-t-on quel premier
bilan pour les majeurs reportage au club
de football de voisins-le-bretonneux et
invité philippe femmes président de
l'entente le chesnay-versailles équipe
de basket et puis du café torréfié
conditionnée par les travailleurs d'un
esat ça se passe à andrésy depuis huit
ans la société mister bean collabore
avec les intégristes avaient fait
l'objectif s'engager pour l'insertion
des personnes en situation de handicap
l'actualité de ce mercredi la
gendarmerie des yvelines a organisé ce
matin des ateliers thématiques sur la
protection économique des entreprises
c'était à l'hôtel novotel du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
une cinquantaine de chefs d'entreprises
étaient donc invités pour être
sensibilisés sur des sujets comme la
cybersécurité ou la protection
bâtimentaire le reportage de célia de
son goût la fraude au président une
personne se fait passer pour le chef
d'entreprise pour obtenir des virements
et prendre la trésorerie voilà l'un des
sujets abordés lors des ateliers
organisés par la gendarmerie des
yvelines le medef est hélas ces pme pour
les chefs d'entreprise l'objectif
d'inviter les chefs d'entreprise c'est
tout simplement dans les prendre en
compte dans une manoeuvre globale pour
les éveiller sur un certain nombre de
sujets et singulièrement en ce moment
puisque l'activité économique reprend et
également dans un contexte où la cyber
délinquance explose en tout trois
ateliers thématiques la protection
bâtimentaire la lutte contre les fraudes
et la cyber protection pour animer un
binôme constitué d'un gendarme et d'un
chef d'entreprise qui a pu subir déjà
des actes malveillants oui ça nous est
arrivé quand quelque chose vous c'est de
réfléchir à comment je peux aussi
l'utiliser pour le bien des autres pour
pouvoir informer dans son échelle
entreprises qui ont bien souvent notion
de sa va pas m'arriver si les autres non
c'est tout le monde est concerné un
dernier atelier été menées par le gign
pour expliquer comment se comporter en
cas d' attaques de haute intensité sur
différents sujets comme le risque
d'attentats en tout ce sont une
cinquantaine de chefs d'entreprise qui
ont participé à ces ateliers j'ai appris
notamment comment réduire les risques
informatique on avait fait j'ai fait le
cycle cybersécurité donc l'e mail et
mots de passe changé bien faire
attention aux fichiers bien faire
attention aux liens et ça c'est sans
civilisation que j'ai entendu m'a permis
de voir que même si je suis bien
organisé il peut y avoir des failles
dans l'entreprise d'autres ateliers sont
prévus dans les mois à venir et toutes
les semaines les gendarmes se rendent au
sein des entreprises pour voir les
problématiques et tenter d'y répondre
c'est la journée mondiale des rhinocéros
l'occasion d'informer sur cette espèce
menacée ne resterait dans le monde que
20000 rhinocéros blancs à l'état sauvage
au zoo de thoiry on s'apprête en
accueillir un goy kitty c'est son nom va
arriver le 29 septembre il remplacera
numériquement bintz abattu en 2018 par
des braconniers de nouveau cédé à 400 go
vous ne le verrez pas encore à l'écran
mais un nouveau rhinocéros blanc va
arriver au zoo de thoiry le 29 septembre
prochain son nom roi kitty un mâle blanc
de 3 ans qui pèse une tonne il provient
du zoo de la boissière du doré en loire
atlantique what it y rejoindra les deux
autres rhinocéros est déjà présent dans
le zoo les visiteurs bien entendu vont
découvrir le wac et y bientôt puisqu'il
va passer quelques jours un petit peu
isolé pour ce faire à son nouvel espace
va directement et dans sa loge et puis
va rejoindre un appartement de bruno et
unesco dans l'espace réservé dans le
coeur de la réserve voit kitty va
remplacer numériquement vince en 2018 ce
rhinocéros avaient été abattu de trois
balles dans la tête et braconné à
l'intérieur de son enclos pour sa corne
malheureusement
la bêtise humaine encore une fois un
clairement qui a conduit à la mort de ce
rhinocéros depuis beaucoup de choses ont
été
encore plus renforcé en termes de
sécurité
encore plus dans cette zone là le
rhinocéros blanc fait partie d'une
espèce extrêmement menacée puisque il
n'en resterait que 20000 en milieu
naturel dans la zee la corne a des
vertus de force et de santé pour guérir
certaines choses on dit que ça guérit le
cancer ou genre de choses et ça peut
malheureusement conduire a tué à ce
genre d'animal pour juste récupérer un
bout de corde qui est vraiment encore
une fois que de la corne en france
ceinte de rhinocéros blancs vivant parc
zoologique
dans l'actualité également le pass
sanitaires bien maintenu pour le moment
partout en france annonce à la
mi-journée du porte parole du
gouvernement mme gabriela talent au
sortir des conseils du conseil des
ministres et le 30 septembre prochain se
passe sanitaire sera aussi obligatoire
pour les jeunes de 12 à 17 ans dans
certains cas aller au cinéma au
restaurant dans les lieux culturels mais
également pour pouvoir pratiquer son
sport dans son association à l'image du
voisin football club les associations
sont confrontés à cette échéance qui
peut se révéler parfois problématique
bixente merrien santisteva la salle j eh
ben j'ai créé ma deuxième dose du combal
agir d'ici une semaine le pass and i ter
sera obligatoire pour les jeunes
sportifs de 12 à 17 ans du voisin
football club pour l'institution qui
compte entre 700 et 800 licenciés au
total l'organisation a dû se faire en
amont nous on a commencé à réfléchir à
ça sur quatre jours d'août donc toute
cette organisation là on l'a testé sur
les premiers matches de coupe de france
avec les seniors le seul petit
problématique reste sur les quatorze qui
sont les plus jeunes ou le certificat de
vaccination est pas encore présent parce
qu'ils sont en cours de vaccination donc
il reste encore tout ce qui est est pcr
enfin à d'autres cas pour pouvoir jouer
au foot sans forcément se faire vacciner
déjà appliquée pour les adultes et donc
bientôt pour les jeunes le pass c'est
l'espoir d'une saison qu'ils puissent se
jouer dans son intégralité contrairement
à l'année passée c'était dur puisque
nous voulait faire des matches comme
avant lui il y avait le cou raide bah
c'est pas du combat oui t on est un peu
dégoûté avec toutes les règles qu'on
devait respecter pour les entraînements
de l'année dernière au bout d'un moment
il y avait une lassitude des joueurs
donc là
ouais beaucoup de fautes ils ont plus
l'habitude d'aller au contact une
reprise qui réjouit tout le monde bien
qu'une problématiques persistent en vue
du 30 septembre 5 à 10 % de l'effectif
total du club n'est pas encore vaccinés
j'ai fait le point ce week-end au niveau
de l'équipe une il y en a deux qui sont
en train d'attendre leur deuxième dose
mais vont faire leur deuxième dose de la
semaine prochaine pour le premier match
officiel il va falloir qu'il fasse un
test et il y en a un qui ne veut pas se
faire vacciner donc pour l'instant ce
sera un test à chaque fois avant les
matches le club de voisins a choisi de
mettre en place une commission de santé
avec des professionnels du secteur pour
préparer la future organisation de ses
joueurs non vaccinés à l'étude
l'hypothèse de payer les tests pour les
matchs aux joueurs concernés
je vous le disais juste avant ce sujet
le passe à lithaire sera bien maintenue
pour le moment partout en france un
l'annoncent à la mi-journée du porte
parole du gouvernement et gabriela
talent au sortir du conseil des
ministres la mesure court officiellement
elle jusqu'au 15 novembre même si un
projet de loi est en préparation pour
aller au delà de cette date autre date à
retenir le 15 octobre où les tests pcr
et antigénique ne seront plus remboursés
philippe femme est avec moi normalement
par visioconférence oui c'est bien le
cas bonsoir oui bonsoir vous êtes le
président de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles un club de basket qui
compte en ce début de saison près de 600
licenciés des catégories qui vont des
jeunes jusqu'aux seniors avec à noter
une équipe féminine en nationale
nationale de basket et votre équipe
masculine qui est en nationale 3 avant
de faire un premier bilan de
l'application du passani terre qui est
déjà effectif donc pour les adultes ce
sera le cas dans quelques semaines
également pour les mineures cette
question le pass sanitaire c'est en
quelque sorte l'espoir qui renaît pour
voir une saison aller à son terme je
rappelle que vous sortez de deux saisons
blanches pour le basket
oui effectivement quasiment deux saisons
blanches la première saison s'est arrêté
je dirais en mars et est malheureusement
la seconde s'est arrêtée le 15 octobre
donc là on peut dire que la saison
dernière a été une saison blanche
oui le pass sanitaire c'est à la fois
une contrainte mais c'est aussi je
dirais l'espoir de
d'imaginer que nous irons au bout de
cette saison en tout cas c'est le
souhait il envie de tous les acteurs de
notre sport que ce soit les dirigeants
bien sûr les joueurs les parents les
jeunes comme les plus anciens nos
pratiquants valides comme nos
pratiquants en situation de handicap
psychique ou physique puisque nous avons
également une section de basket adapter
une section de basket fauteuil justement
alors en parlant d' adaptation vu que la
pratique n'a pas été autorisée pendant
un certain temps je rappelle juste les
dates le 9 juin dernier la pratique en
intérieur a été réautorisée mais sans
contact ce n'est que depuis le 30 juin
que vous pouvez leur pratique et on va
dire sans contrainte comment ça s'est
déroulé du coup pour votre club sur sept
saisons et demie il ya eu des de
l'adaptation des entraînements peut-être
à l'extérieur pour continuer quand même
un semblant pratique alors effectivement
à partir du 15 mai là où nous pouvions
rapidement reprendre en extérieur
puisque au niveau des sols c'était
toujours interdite nous avons essayé de
pratiquer le temps le permet tant d
entraînement pour pour les les jeunes
essentiellement et pas pour les adultes
parce que les adultes avaient tellement
décroché que ce n'était pas envisageable
de les remettre je dirais dans le bain
immédiatement et puis et puis ensuite
nous nous avons à partir de mi-août mis
en place des stages de préparation de
redémarrage de la saison et puis tout se
passe bien puisque effectivement on va
dire au fur et à mesure je dirais des
niveaux nous avons pu remettre en place
de nos entraînements et aujourd'hui nous
sommes en plein dedans tous les ai tous
les entraînements ont repris nous avons
bénéficié de deux salles qui ont été
réhabilités au niveau 2
duchesne héros comme cours ce qui nous a
été effectivement à déployer de manière
substantielle de nos entraînements et et
tout va bien puisque je dirai après
avoir est une année blanche mais qui
surfe un an des licenciés nous a quand
même permis de terminer premier club
fédéral de france en basket avec 845
censier et 907 au total avec nos
sections handisport est parce qu est
adapté nous en sommes déjà près de 600
licenciés alors qu'en réalité on sait
très bien que sur les plus petits c'est
à dire notre école de mini basket qui
comprend plus de 200 jeunes nous en
sommes je dirais à peu près à un tiers
de recrutement dans la mesure où ces
jeunes avec leurs parents arrivent dans
le club après la rentrée des classes
alors concernant le pass sanitaire je
rappelle que vous êtes philippe femmes
donc le président de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles puisqu'il n'ya pas
les petits bordeaux d'information qui
apparaissent ce soir le pasa d'iter est
obligatoire pour les seniors pour les
majeures depuis déjà plusieurs semaines
comment ça s'est passé dans votre club
cette mise en application est ce que ça
s'est plutôt bien déroulé ça a été
difficile à mettre en place
écoutez nous avions une crainte
effectivement que un certain nombre de
personnes ne soient pas vacciner et il
nécessite évidemment qu'ils présentent
des tests pcr ou antigénique mais en
réalité la plupart de nos pratiques en
jeu par des adultes 1
avait anticipé puisque il ya une grande
campagne de vaccination durant l'été et
la plupart avaient anticipé et même
niveau nos équipes premières nos équipes
de jeunes je dirais u17 15 certains même
avait anticipé puisque il avait entendu
dire que la vaccination sera obligatoire
pour les 12 17 ans donc en réalité ça
s'est plutôt bien passé
on a perdu quelques éléments non pas
parce qu'il ne veut dire 'il refusé la
vaccination et parce que souvent et je
parle des raids et plus jeunes les
parents ne souhaitaient pas qu'il se
fasse vacciner et on leur a simplement
donné rendez-vous une feuille pas
sanitaire sera abandonnée on espère
bientôt
ça représente beaucoup de joueurs non
une dizaine sur sur l'ensemble donc
c'est vraiment très minoritaire et c'est
un souci qui a été levé assez rapidement
quand on a vu en train de reprendre à la
fois les entraînements et puis les
inscriptions alors justement le pass
sanitaire qui était obligatoire pour les
majeurs va l'être également pour les
mineurs à partir du 30 septembre ça vous
fait une difficulté supplémentaire ou
c'est pas forcément une appréhension
pour vous cette date qui arrive qui
arrive très vite c'est dans une semaine
le 30 septembre
c'est une difficulté supplémentaire mais
c'est pas une appréhension parce que
déjà on a eu l'occasion de se faire la
main sur les adultes alors évidemment
les adultes chez nous représentent 30%
notre effectif pour 70 % de jeunes dont
il est clair que l'enjeu est plus
important sur les sur les jeunes en
termes d'effectifs mais là dedans je
dirais on a quand même notre école de
mini basket qui a moins de 12 ans qui
n'est pas concernée donc on a quand même
une frange importante de notre
population qui ne sera pas concerné par
le passé unitaire mais pour les autres
on a déjà eu l'occasion de discuter avec
les parents qui comprennent tout à fait
et qui d'ailleurs ont quelque part
comprennent la démarche dans la mesure
où c'est aussi une sécurité et c'est le
gage de pouvoir continuer à
jouer et à s'entraîner tout au long de
la saison sans interruption comme
malheureusement nous l'avons vécu les
deux années passées mais ce qu'on le
rappelle le passé l'été est obligatoire
pour les entraînements mais aussi c'est
à présenter bien sûr pour pouvoir
disputer les compétitions donc vous ne
craignez pas sera la dernière question
une fuite des joueurs sur les sur les
prochaines semaines vous l'avez dit les
les parents sont plutôt ouverts sur sur
ce thème de la vaccination
ils sont ouverts bon maintenant on
comprend on a tout à fait compris les
les parents qui ont dit qu'il ne
souhaitait pas vacciner l'ensemble du
ruy ligne aurait un petit peu les
conséquences que cela pourrait avoir on
les a rassurés en leur disant que mon
toute façon la vaccination allant bon
train on peut imaginer quand même et les
indicateurs sanitaires s'améliorant de
semaine en semaine on peut quand même
espérer que les pouvoirs publics
lèveront tôt ou tard je dirais les
contraintes ne serait ce qu'avec les
chances du 15 novembre qui est la date
je dirais
de l'urgence sanitaire en espérant qu'à
cette époque là effectivement il
inquiète heures permettront de lever le
passé ni terre ce qui permettra quand
même à des jeunes qui aujourd'hui sont
en attente de pouvoir reprendre
l'entraînement car le 15 novembre la
saison est loin d'être terminée même
s'il se dit que le gouvernement prépare
un projet de loi pour peut-être et bien
rendre le passage iter le pouvoir aller
au delà de cette date du 15 novembre que
vous évoquez merci philippe femme
d'avoir été avec nous
vous êtes le président de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles un club de basket
bien sûr basée dans les yvelines et
puisqu'on parle de sport du football on
connaît désormais les affiches du 4e
tour de la coupe de france le tirage au
sort a été effectué ce mercredi à midi
où il se déplacera sur le terrain de
saint michel pour leur entrée en lice
versailles en nationale ii recevra
brétigny et poissy se rendra à gretz
tournan les mureaux accueilleront fleury
chatou irak ainsi hardricourt à
champagne 95 trappe affrontera le puck
voisins aura encore fort à faire avec un
nouveau club de régionale 2 face aux
vies si noah c'est courbevoie tout comme
plaisir qui jouera contre le racing une
équipe de nationale 3 chambourcy
affrontera villeneuve ablon enfin le
petit poucet des yvelines bréval on y
recevra vincennes sept divisions
séparent les deux équipes le match les
matches sont programmés sur les week-end
des 2 et 3 octobre prochains
[Musique]
une collaboration 100% évinoise à
présent mr bean est une société de
torréfaction basée à montigny le
bretonneux à l'entreprise propose une
alternative aux capsules et dosettes de
café avec du café en grains et elle
travaille depuis huit ans avec les as tu
vu stave eiffel qui est basée à andrésy
pour torréfié conditionner le café
directement sur place focus avec justin
brasier mélanie poker
spécialisée dans le café en grains mr
bean travaille en partenariat avec les
actes buste avait fait elle depuis 2013
la société de torréfaction installé un
atelier sur place à andrésy le but
s'engager pour l'insertion des personnes
en situation de handicap
au début les attaques commencé à
conditionner nos cafés ensuite ils ont
fait notre plateforme logistique et
depuis presque quatre ans maintenant on
a installé notre nouveau torréfacteur à
lézat de gustave eiffel du coup depuis
le café vert jusqu'à l'expédition chez
nos clients en passant par la
torréfaction tout est fait fort nos
collègues les travailleurs en situation
de handicap au total ils sont une
dizaine à travailler avec mr bean chacun
prépare les commandes s'occupe du
conditionnement et de la torréfaction
reçoit deux des grandes toques ap et en
fait on le cuit en fait
à votre pharmacien
dans cet atelier il travaille le grès
une vingtaine d'heures par semaine
objectif être au coeur du métier c'est
vrai que du café on
on n'avait jamais fait
donc c'était un beau challenge de
pouvoir travailler sur des produits
alimentaires
et de deux de faire découvrir sa à
chacun l'intérêt c'est aussi
l'utilisation des machines donc accéder
à la technique et bien sûr faire
respecter les règles de sécurité par
rapport à thématique aujourd'hui les
attaques buste avait pelle conditionne
entre 3 et 4 tonnes de café par mois
[Musique]
c'est l'embarquement est prévue dimanche
prochain l'office de tourisme
intercommunal terre de seine vous
propose de prendre place à bord du tiw
anneaux pour une croisière sur la seine
ouais là vous voyez cette croisière
particularité elle sera musical le
rendez vous est fixé à 14 heures 30 à
l'embarcadère rené albert de conflans
sainte honorine est la croisière vous
emmènera de conflent à andrésy avant de
revenir à son point de départ à bord un
concert de 45 minutes dans le cadre des
halls factory festival le off plus de 20
concerts et des ateliers de fabrication
d'instruments de musique sont proposés
c'est jusqu'au 16 octobre sur le
territoire de la communauté urbaine
grand paris seine et oise et le show
sera assuré sur la scène par le groupe
des fire l'ip semaine les fire les deux
semaines avec leur cuir et leurs cuivres
en fête ce sont des joyeux drilles qui
volent en escadrille de pilotes de la
seconde guerre mondiale qui revisite les
standards du répertoire jamaïcain de la
nouvelle orléans ayant reprennent aussi
les standards des années 80 aussi des
musiques des séries comme magnum ou à
l'époque avec papy boyington je crois
que c'était les têtes brûlées en fait
voilà ça va être une ambiance assez
festive sur sur le bateau
[Musique]
rendez vous donc ce dimanche 26
septembre pour la croisière musicale
embarquement à 14h30 tarif de 15 euros
pour les adultes 9 euros pour les
enfants le port du masque et le pass
sanitaires seront obligatoires plus
d'informations sur le site de l'office
de tourisme terre de seine
www.cr au pluriel tiré deux tirets
seine.fr le site internet ne s'affiche
pas effectivement ce soir à voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir
suivi et il nous excuser encore pour ces
quelques problèmes techniques
l'essentiel c'est qu'on ait pu vous
proposer cette édition d'information
locale belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]